en direct sur figaro là il ce 7 juin
dans quelques minutes nous serons en
direct depuis mon marsan dans les landes
en région nouvelle aquitaine pour
assister à une conférence de presse
concernant le variant indien renommée
variant delta par l' oms ce variant
préoccupe les autorités sanitaires
puisque des dizaines de cas de variants
indiens sont apparues ces derniers jours
un plan d'action spécifique devrait donc
être annoncés pour contenir l'épidémie
donc dans quelques minutes la situation
sanitaire s'est dégradé depuis quelques
semaines affirmé cécile bigot de keyser
la préfète du département des landes et
il ya quelques heures
ajoutant que la rs estime à une
cinquantaine le nombre de personnes
concernées
et justement c'est cécile bigot de
keyser préfète des landes que nous
devrions entendre dans quelques minutes
on annonce également l'intervention et
la prise de paroles de didier couteaud
délégué départemental de la rs l' agence
régionale de santé des landes et bruno
devait directeur académique des services
de les nuques de l'éducation nationale
des landes pour commenter cet événement
en direct sur figaro live j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir avec moi en plateau est
à côté de moi marc cherki qui est
journaliste au service science du figaro
bonjour marc merci d'être en direct avec
nous et vous qui nous qui nous suivez en
direct sur lefigaro.fr et sur youtube et
si vous avez des questions ou des
commentaires à nous faire mais vous
n'hésitez pas je les règes et leur jeu
les relaieraient à marcq cher qui nous
sommes là pour vous pour vous éclairer
et tenter de répondre à tout ce qui vous
passe par la tête
en rapport avec cet événement de
l'actualité marché requis cette prise de
parole elle a quelque chose d'un peu
inquiétant on va dire ce variant indien
dont on entend parler déjà depuis
quelques temps
la france s'est engagée et pourtant à un
retour à une vie normale progressive
avec l'allègement des contraintes
sanitaires et une décrue confirmée un
jour après jour du coc vite 19
est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter de ce
variant indiens qui commencent à pointer
plus que son nez en nouvelles aquitaine
et en particulier dans les landes
alors il faut le surveiller comme
varian celui qui arrive dans les landes
mais il est également plus présent
encore en ile de france la semaine
dernière santé publique france dans le
nombre de cas qui recensait sur
l'ensemble du territoire ont recensé
davantage en ile de france
quand
la dague dans les landes à dax ou halak
à dax dans les landes
donc il faut le surveiller ça reste
encore un niveau très très faible il ya
moins de 100 cas qui ont été recensés et
publiée sur le territoire sur l'ensemble
du territoire national
et ceci étant on peut regretter que ça
prenne un peu de temps pour arriver à
identifier les cas ce qu'ont dit les
premiers cas serait apparue il ya
environ un petit moins et c'est
simplement aujourd'hui qu'on va avoir vu
des données un peu nouvelle sur ce qui
se passe dans les landes
vendredi où nous disait il ya 50 cas qui
ont été recensés on va voir combien il y
en a aujourd'hui après les séquençages
qui ont été faits récemment alors je
salue tout de suite
kriss kross infidèle internautes du
figaro.fr et figaro live qui a
l'habitude de nous faire passer ces
questions ces commentaires en rapport
avec les directs que nous diffusons à
bien il s'interroge pourquoi s'inquiéter
en fait on nous fait la même propagande
de la peur avec le variant anglais et
pourtant la décrue jour après jour
alors est ce qu'il ya de d'inquiétant
avec le baril un dia par rapport aux
autres variantes comme le barrio anglais
c'est qu'il est plus contagieux il a un
taux de contamination accrue entre 20 à
50% alors
un ministre britannique dit ce week-end
40% c'est à peu près le milieu de la
fourchette
l'étude britannique sur laquelle on se
fonde qui a été publiée la semaine
dernière dit elle entre 20 et 50% et ils
prennent la moyenne de 35%
donc c'est ça qui est inquiétant c'est
qu'il est mais il se propage plus vite
que le variant anglais qui lui-même se
propager entre 40 et 70 % plus vite que
le mariage classé historique
donc il est vraiment extrêmement
transmis ceci étant notre internaute a
raison de poser la question
parce que on a parlé par exemple c'est
pas la première fois que une préfecture
fait d'une conférence de presse quand il
ya eu le variant breton bas pendant
trois semaines de suite le préfet
de la région autour du département
autour de lannion c'était à organiser
des conférences de presse pour expliquer
le nombre de cas 1 précisant il avait
d'ailleurs donné des informations un peu
mauvaise au départ qui avait été précisé
la semaine qui avait suivi cédera donc
bon c'est ça dénote simplement qu'il
faut surveiller faut rester vigilant
voilà cette crise cross a précisé
également que ce parisien qui est
évidemment très présents sur le
territoire indien et mais du coup il est
contagieux oui certes mais il est plus
et pardon en inde même malgré le variant
indien s'abaisse jour en jour donc c'est
il relativise d'inquiétude dont il faut
faire preuve alors ses services de jour
en jour mais sa baisse de jour en jour
par rapport à des centaines de milliers
voire des centaines de milliers de cas
par jour je crois qu'on était monté en
randonnée autour des 400 mille cas
quotidiens à partir du moment où les
gens sont prévenus ils peuvent prendre
et respecter les gestes barrières et ça
ça permet de réduire la diffusion des
vaccinations oui bien sûr la vaccination
puisque on s'aperçoit que la vaccination
fonctionne sur les populations les plus
fragiles en tout cas elles sont moins
impactés désormais qu'elle ne l'était
avant la vaccination on y reviendra là
dessus
à propos de deux d'impact de ce variant
indien de sa gravité de alors on a vu sa
contagion l île est transmissible de
l'ordre de 40% de plus en moyenne que le
variant britannique qui lui-même étaient
50% plus contagieux que le variant
historique souche
kriss kross toujours nous demande
contagieux oui mais est il plus mortel
qui n'était pas encore on avait dit pour
le vario anglais le variant al fahm non
avec la nouvelle dénomination de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
est entrée en vigueur la semaine
dernière
il utilise donc des noues de l'alphabet
des mots dont les premières lettres de
l'alphabet grec pour dénommer les
différents variant d'inquiétude ou
préoccupant pour éviter de stigmatiser
les pays on va dire dire variant indien
on a l'impression que c'est la voie la
responsable et le variant britanniques
ont l'impression que ce sont les nos
amis britanniques qui sont responsables
du variant donc pour éviter cette
stigmatisation va diront on april oms a
choisi deux voilà de nommer ces variants
avec la première lettre de l'alphabet
grics voilà dacquois il vous est coupée
marque a excusé le juge magi est ce que
je disais ça devait pas être très très
sympa si c'était sur la partie de la
deûle à la dangerosité la dangerosité et
la dangerosité du haillan alpha donc l
année dernière en décembre de l'année
dernière on avait dit le variant alpha
est plus dangereux et le plus mortel que
la souche historique est la même et qui
a publié une étude dans une autre revue
pour dire qu'en fait finalement bah non
il n'était pas plus dangereux ni plus
mortel que ce qu'ils avaient dit
initialement il avait simplement été
débordé par probablement ils avaient été
probablement étaient débordées par
l'afflux passion des patients à la
charge des urgences
si vous venez nous rejoindre à l'instant
nous sommes sur le point de diffuser une
conférence de presse depuis
mont-de-marsan dans les landes en
nouvelles aquitaine conférence de presse
en lien avec le variant indien variant
delta a nommé comme ça désormais par l'
oms ce variant delta qui commence à
inquiéter les autorités sanitaires
puisque quelques cas désormais positif à
ce variant qui est autrement plus encore
transmissibles on va dire que le variant
vitesse britannique commencent à
impacter cette région mais comme nous
l'a dit marc cherkli en plateau et en
direct avec moi en ce début d'après midi
et journalistes et aux services
scientifiques garot il ya aussi beaucoup
de cas en ile-de-france de ce variant
indien on y reviendra dans quelques
minutes je salue christian léon
toussaint qui nous a rejoints dans le
chat du figaro.fr il fait comme comme
beaucoup d'entre vous c'est à dire qu'il
participe au tchad du figaro live pour
nous commenter cette actualité sur le
variant à dire il me poser ses questions
christian de toussaint qui disent et en
inde qui a le plus de laboratoires
pharmaceutiques pour la fabrication des
vars des vaccins points de suspension ou
si j'interprète son commentaire à
christian léon tout ça on pourrait se
dire que et on fabrique beaucoup de
vaccins en inde et pourtant ils sont
très largement impacté par par le cos
vie de 19
oui mais toute la population
n'est pas vacciné est effectivement un
des sous traitants d'astrazeneca est
présent en est
ils ont arrêté d'ailleurs pendant un
temps de fournir des vaccins au système
kovacs qui est le système international
pourrait fabriquer leur propre
mobilisation
voilà pour alimenter leur propre
population au détriment des autres pays
dans le monde pour lequel il devait
fournir ce vaccin donc effectivement
c'est un des pays un des plus gros
fabricants de vaccins ou monde mais ils
sont plus d'un milliard d'un milliard
deux cent mille plus d'un milliard deux
cents millions d'habitants donc
ils ont pas encore vaccinés toute la
populace qu'on peut comprendre 66
millions en france on a quand même un
rythme assez soutenu et on est loin
encore d'arriver au terme de cette
campagne de vaccination
revenons en france justement la région
nouvelle aquitaine marc cherkli et
c'était l'une des moins impactés l'une
des moins touchés ces derniers mois par
le commis 19 et pourtant le variant à
dire commence à faire quelques quelques
dégâts on va dire oui elle explique ce
variant bien touche désormais c'est que
les personnes et les patients ont un
lien avec la grande bretagne ou le
variant à dire est très présent oullins
même alors ce qui était rassurant où
tout départ du variant indien c'est que
on arrivait à remonter les cas et on
arrive d'ailleurs dans la plupart des
cas et encore 15 jours santé publique
grandissaient mans on s'inquiète pas du
variant indien parce qu'on arrive à
remonter toutes les chaînes et donc il
ya toujours un lien avec soie lin le
n'est pas les maldives la suisse
l'espagne des pays sur lesquels dans
lesquels on m'avait repéré des bars
gagnant là ce qui est plus préoccupant à
ce qu'il faut surveiller c'est que c'est
une propagation autochtones ya qu'on
n'arrive pas à retrouver l'origine d'une
personne qui aurait été en lien avec une
personne qui rentreraient d'un d'une
épave des pays dans lesquels on aurait
le se marier comme si ce variant indiens
avaient surgi de n'importe où et pas moi
il ya des gens qui ont été contaminés
c'est pas moi n'a pas remonté toute là
tout d'abord elle n'arrive pas a rappelé
toute la mauricie
merci de nous suivre en direct sur
figaro live le figaro.fr pour dans
quelques instants suivre en direct avec
nous la conférence de presse de la
préfète des landes
une intervention qui sera délivré en
direct et en public pour nous parler de
l'évolution du variant indiens qui
commencent à inquiéter les autorités
sanitaires sur place et les mesures qui
seront prises pour freiner cette ce
début d'épidémie ou en tout cas diminuer
le nombre de clusters qui sont détectés
sur place kriss kross toujours
internautes sur figaro live qui nous
pose beaucoup de questions ont ce début
d'après midi sur le sujet ils
l'affirment effectivement ce qui est pas
fou le confinement n'est pas possible en
1/2 pas comme ici on rappelait plus d'un
milliard deux cent mille habitants en
inde un milliard deux cents millions
d'habitants effectivement en inde ce qui
fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de gens à contrôler kriss kross toujours
c'est vrai ça je croyais qu'on avait
fermé nos frontières avec ce pays
asiatique
alors oui effectivement il ya eu des
déplacements de populations indiennes
par avion qui ont dû se faire avec
l'europe qui ont possiblement généré jeu
l'udc et quelques cluster d'abord mais
est-ce que ça a été les frontières ont
été fermées avec avec l'inde pas
complètement à ce que je sache les
frontières sont fermées ou pas avec
l'unss et que de toute manière le vario
indien est présent dans d'autres pays
donc les gens qui viennent d'autres pays
peuvent apporter le
être porteur du marion indien c'est
simplement ça les frontières ont été
fermées de manière assez dur avec l'un
mais pas avec le népal enfin à ma
connaissance ni avec l'espagne ni avec
l'angleterre où il faudrait qu'une une
décision massive et qui bloque
définitivement les frontières avec tous
les pays qui nous entourent puisqu'il
suffit d'une personne pour démarrer la
chaîne on va dire de la contamination
par exemple il ya simplement des tests
pcr qui doivent être faits de moins 72
heures au départ et est moins 36 heures
même maintenant entre les deux pays donc
voilà une personne qui a déjà été
contaminées qui n'a pas encore développé
des six qui n'est pas encore parti du
virus au sens du test pcr peut rentrer
en france en provenance de suisse donc
voilà c'est tout cas le robinet n'est
pas de faire toute la difficulté de
fermeture des frontières
que sait-on en précisément de ce variant
indien de ce variant delta pourquoi
d'ailleurs on l'appelle variant maintien
si on peut juste faire un peut-être
petites fiches informatives sur le sujet
en bas qui s'appelle marion indien parce
que il émerge en inde
simplement il est repéré là bas on
décembre novembre fin novembre ou en
fait et ils essaient conseil là bas afin
de vendre on trouve les premières traces
la main et on a pris l'habitude
dénommé les différents lignée de varian
inc
plus d'une soixantaine active n'y a pas
que le variant à dire delta morina les
autres il ya bien eu énormément d'autrui
et on ne parle que delta pourquoi alors
on parle pas que de delta il ya delta il
y en a un autre aussi qu'il surveillait
par l'om est ce qu'il appelait cas pas
mais qui est moins contagieux
semble-t-il pour l'instant que le
variant delta
[Musique]
et il y en aurait des dizaines d'autres
simplement donc possiblement chez nous
également alors chez nous aussi oui il y
en a un qui a été identifié notamment à
l'hôpital henri mondor
qui est plus présent encore sur le
territoire français qui représente plus
d'un pour cent des contaminations selon
les dernières études ont été réalisées
sur le cas il vous est également présent
sur le chat de youtube sur le compte
youtube du figaro et sur ce compte là
vous avez des commentaires et des
questions dont je vais faire par marc
cherki de vito design demande lequel des
vaccins et le plus efficace contre ce
variant à dire avant de répondre à de
vita design peut-être est-ce que les
vaccins sont efficaces contre ce variant
indien l'ariane deux études une étude
britannique et mines et une angles une
étude française qui disent que il ya
deux vaccins qui semble être efficace
qui sont les vaccins pfizer et le vaccin
astrazeneca est donc ces deux vaccins
sont efficaces
alors je dis de la rn messager mais
également avec le dispositif des vaccins
non enfin enfin c'est pas tout à fait un
vaccin l'ancienne c'est un vaccin
adénovirus donc c'est aussi une
technologie en intermédiaires
nouvelle enfin monter un peu différente
du vaccin et rennes et il y en a un qui
est plus efficace que l'autre les
vaccins et rennes semble avoir une
efficacité meilleur que les vaccins
desnoyers russe dont 109 either moderna
modern art où la pâte et c'était
d'accord a priori si on utilise la même
technologie mais qu'il faut voir c'est
que ils sont protecteurs à condition
d'être vraiment matinée s'est bien avoir
les deux doses aujourd'hui avec un
trailer par exemple qu'il nécessite deux
injections on ne sera véritablement
protégée que dans combien de temps alors
ça dépend quand vous un deuxième dose
une semaine à la deuxième dose est donc
la première boucle pour considérer
qu'être deux mois première injection on
est on dans une protection
sept semaines après la première
injection il à condition d'avoir qui
peut varier
on a quatre et six semaines donc une
semaine après la deuxième dose on est
bien protégé contrariant indien est en
tout cas les trois grandes familles de
mario grenier
on va considérer donc grosso modo c'est
au bout de deux mois après la première
injection et en faisant faire la
deuxième injection deux mois après on
peut considérer qu'on est là protection
optimale une semaine après la deuxième
une semaine après la deuxième injection
et du coup il ya même véhicule qui
seront proposés en france par le pasteur
de faire
un vaccin astrazeneca puis avec ça je ne
connais pas encore les résultats d'une
machination triplettes avec astrazeneca
en france dans les huit françaises dans
l'étude des amis qui sont les dire que
c'était protecteur environ 60 % une fois
qu'on avait les deux axes et astrazeneca
et autour de 90 % de plus de 80% oui ces
décès les 90% ce qui est et ce qui est
assez considérable en fait c'est plus
est plus important en tout cas que le
vaccin habituels contre la grippe
annuelle
je sais pas si vous avez les images que
nous voyons nous en direct depuis nos
studios
la conférence de presse est sur le point
de débuter on voit l'installation pour
l'instant des protagonistes qui devrait
intervenir lors de cette conférence de
presse donc au sujet de ce variant
indien variant deltort
qui devrait nous en dire plus sur l'état
de la propagation de ce variant qui
inquiète les autorités sanitaires en
tout cas depuis
les landes en nouvelles aquitaine à
l'intervention depuis mont-de-marsan sur
place et on devrait avoir les
interventions également du délégué
départemental de la rs l' agence
régionale de santé puis normalement
également un le directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale des
landes bruno brevets si vous venez nous
rejoindre en direct sur figaro lave
lefigaro.fr et youtube et vous n'hésitez
pas à nous faire part de vos
commentaires nous poser vos questions en
lien avec avec ce variant alors qu'on
voit arriver la préfète des langues
qu'on va écouter
je n'ai pas pour l'instant le sont mais
je pense que c'est normal puisqu'elle
n'a pas encore pris la parole
voilà on entend ça y est
là
la préfète qui demande à ce que la pièce
soit aéré on l'a entendu marque
on remarque on va jouer les directs
jusqu'au bout marque vous avez un petit
souci avec votre micro me dit-on en
régie donc on va remédier au problème on
va vous le changez en attendant que la
préfète des landes interviennent au
sujet donc de ce variant indien qui
suscite l'inquiétude des autorités
sanitaires en nouvelles aquitaine où une
dizaine de cas qui monte à une
cinquantaine de cas ont été répertoriés
sur sur la nouvelle aquitaine mais comme
vous disais marque cherki journaliste au
service santé figaro il ya aussi
beaucoup de cas en ile de france
on y reviendra peut-être après
l'intervention de la préfète
de toute façon je décès pour que les
personnes qui sont dans l'eau d'atomes
bonjour
je
du kenya témoin
n'hésitez pas à donner d'abord oui on va
essayer oui c'est vrai avec des potes
ses balcons asco
bien alors je suis avec le directeur
départemental de l'agencé régionale de
santé didier couteaud à ma bouche et
l'inspecteur d'académie ou nombreux
verbe ans directeur des services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
alors une terrible explosion qui sont en
bois est ce que tous ceux qui sont aux
visions veulent bien le foot leur micro
crèche chacun pourra poser des questions
et à ce moment là la personne qui veut
qui est en vision en audio qui veut
prendre la parole pour ouvrir au micro
mais juste pour s'exprimer parce que
c'est vrai que c'est nous c'est fait un
dépôt terrible voilà nous voulions vous
faire aujourd'hui 1 1 contre la
situation de la la situation sanitaire
dans le département des landes
c'est une situation qui n'est pas
particulièrement inquiétant mais qui
méritent de la vigilance puisque nous
avons d'une part un taux d'incidence qui
a augmenté sensiblement depuis quelques
semaines mais qui reste néanmoins modéré
puisqu'il se situe selon les jours
depuis la fin de la semaine dernière
entre 80 et 100 ça donc c'est donc un
taux d'incidence qui reste modérée mais
qui a quand même pas mal augmenté depuis
quelques semaines et puis
l'autre élément qui nous incite à être
très attentifs c'est la présence de
personnes contaminées par le ver ayant
dit variant indien à l'est celui d'un
d'un premier criblage des tests réalisés
on a donc un d'un plan d'action qui est
mis en place qui a déjà commencé à se
mettre en place
qui repose sur les trois piliers que
vous connaissez testé avec un
renforcement des dispositifs de test et
d'identification de la nature du virus
et c'est la variole le virus initiale ou
le variant
un des différents agents notamment le
verlan 10 indiens donc renforcement des
opérations de tests et des opérations de
d'identification de type de virus
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
le volet alerté bien sûr avec un
renforcement de toutes les actions
visant à rappeler à nos concitoyens
qu'il faut qu'il soit très attentif aux
gestes barrières mais également à
l'isolément et puis protection avec les
allemands gracieux et avec la
vaccination
voilà une situation sanitaire qui n'est
pas très inquiétante mais qui nécessite
de la vigilance du fait du taux
d'incidence et de personnes apparaissant
comme contaminé par des variantes 10
indiens à l'issue d'un premier criblage
des tests et un plan d'action au titre
des trois volets tester alerté protégés
que nous allons vous vous présenter
ensemble je vais passer la parole à
didier couteaud qui va vous faire un
point bien précis sur la situation
sanitaire est présenté le volet testé
pour une bonne partie de ce volet clef
alors quelques mots aussi pour compléter
sur la situation sanitaire est
effectivement la situation elle n'est
pas inquiétante pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord les personnes qui ont été
touchées parmi ces 29 cas ce sont des
personnes relativement jeunes sans
comorbidités on a simplement cinq
personnes qui sont âgés de 50 ans et
plus dont une personne 75 ans donc
premier élément deuxième élément les
vingt-neuf personnes sont toutes hors
schéma vaccinal
ça veut dire qu'il n'a qu'une seule
parmi ces 29 qui acheva vaccinale
complet avec une première injection et
puis un rappel et ce rappel a été fait
simplement deux jours avant tournée mise
à jour donc cette contamination
donc ce qui veut dire et vous le savez
que normalement on considère qu'il ya un
délai de 15 jours pour que le vaccin
soit complètement en efficacité
donc ça je pense que ce sont vraiment
deux éléments qui sont importants
et puis enfin parmi ces 29 personnes
on n'a bien sûr aucun décès et pas
d'hospitalisation lié à ces situations
là en tout cas aucune personne en
réanimation
et les quelques hospitalisation que l'on
a sont pour des personnes qui parfois
ont fait des excès de doliprane donc
rien de rien de grave en tout cas sur 20
mois par rapport à la situation actuelle
alors sur nos premières mesures ont
effectivement c'est conforter la
première chose c'est bien de conforter
le diagnostic qui a été posé et
notamment sur l'existence du variant
indien on a travaillé vous le savez avec
des criblage qui ont été faits par nos
laboratoires
plusieurs laboratoires concernés axe bio
exalabs est forte et bio bien évidemment
la première chose c'est de conforter ce
diagnostic et donc on travaille
aujourd'hui dans la semaine sur des
compléments d' analyse avec la méthode
dite de séquençage on va travailler avec
les trois chu de la nouvelle aquitaine
pour étudier on est en l'estiment à peu
près 100 à 200 tests pour lesquels on
n'a pas de certitudes sur les résultats
donc l'objectif est bien de confirmer
les résultats
et puis deuxième point on va travailler
également avec le centre national de
référence du chu de lyon pour que tous
les résultats de demain mardi deux
cargos vide
donc on l'estiment à 70 à 80 cas donc
soit tu sais quand c'est quel que soit
le criblage et quel que soit le résultat
autrement dit dans le département on a
une situation un tout petit peu atypique
puisque si la majorité les départements
nouvelle écrite n ont
les variants on représente 81 82 % à 85
%
on a une situation un peu atypique
puisque on est aujourd'hui à 50% dans ce
département
qu'ils sortent en variant variant
britannique
darian sud africains brésiliens ou
peut-être variant indien donc d'où
l'intérêt de travailler vraiment sur ces
séquençages pour redéfinir si on est
bien sûr du variant indiens aussi on est
sur des mutations de ce variant indien
qui a été donc séquences et dans 29
situation vendredi au delà de la
mobilisation des laboratoires bien
évidemment ce qu'on souhaite c'est que
chacun aille vers les lieux de dépistage
six communautés de communes ou
agglomérations qui sont ciblés 13
laboratoires qui sont aujourd'hui
concernées dans ces zones donc pour
inviter les personnes à se faire
dépister
donc par la méthode pcr pour autant on
va mener des actions spécifiques de
dépistage je vais laisser passer la dure
[Musique]
là
pour les actions de dépistage ciblé dans
des entreprises ou dans des hébergements
collectifs
pour le dire autrement dans 22 ans no 29
situation on a des personnes qui
travaillent dans les mêmes entreprises
ou en tout cas qui sont à l'origine donc
de kloster dans ces entreprises dont il
y en a cinq
donc évidemment l'objectif c'est bien de
retravailler sur un dépistage global au
sein de ces entreprises
et puis j'ai parlé également d'un centre
d'hébergement puisque un centre
d'hébergement pour personnes on va dire
fragile et concerner également par un
parent au moins un cas donc là aussi on
va proposer proposer du dépistage
systématique sur les mesures de
dépistage on va continuer également
parent travail important donc je passe
la main
la parole à l'inspecteur d'académie
voulez vous
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît est ce que monsieur
périple un peu coupé son micro sans
mettre en cause m
[Musique]
excusez moi monsieur je retrouve mes
réflexes de maître d'école
vous ne prenez pas monsieur péricaud
et
sans doute ce qu'il dit est très
intéressant mais je pense l'être
davantage
mais si je pense qu'il a coupé court
monsieur père etc ou non je pense qu'il
a coûté son
depuis deux ans
[Musique]
tous
connecté
[Musique]
oh
monsieur kérékou
[Musique]
est ce que quelqu'un peut lui mettre sa
canne
[Musique]
elles tombent jour
bien mesdames messieurs donc on va
reprendre le cours de sept points presse
par rapport à ce qui est indiqué mme la
préfète le monsieur le directeur
départemental vous préciser quelle est
la situation aujourd'hui dans les écoles
les collèges les lycées du département
des landes puisque tous les
établissements scolaires restent bien
ouverts c'est la première information
depuis quatre semaines nous avons le
même nombre de classes fermées
chaque semaine se dire que avec
l'apparition effectivement de ce variant
nous n'avons pas une augmentation du
nombre de classes et d'écoles fermées
tout ça étant liés au protocole
sanitaire que nous appliquions dans les
établissements scolaires dans les
collèges dans les lycées comme l'indiqué
mme la préfète nous avons souhaité en
fait renforcer les différentes mesures
qui sont déjà mises en oeuvre
la première des mesures c'est d'abord
les mesures de dépistage comme ça vous a
été indiquée donc nous allons en
quasiment multiplié par deux le nombre
de tests salivaires et réalisé en école
et en collège puisque nous passerons à
peu près de 3000 vaut environ 6000 test
salivaire pour cette semaine
les tests ont déjà commencé donc
aujourd'hui et se poursuivront toute
cette semaine
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
s'agissant des lycées et des personnels
de l'éducation nationale des autotests
sont à disposition ont été distribués
donc depuis quinze jours trois semaines
nous avons en fait un stock de plus de
1000 autotests au sein des services
départementaux qui peuvent être
déployées en tant que de besoin si dans
des écoles dans des collèges dans des
lycées ils manquent de tout est donc
vous voyez la stratégie en fait les
doubles vigilance d'une part et d'autre
part un volontarisme pour conserver les
écoles les collèges et lycées ouverts
mais aussi pour assurer chacune et
chacun sur la nécessité de se faire
dépister et de permettre et bien la
poursuite des actes danse et d'humour
vous voyez une augmentation du nombre de
dépistages sur auto test test salivaire
déploiement des protocoles sanitaires
pour permettre justement à ce que bien
chacun puisse avoir accès à ces tests et
qu'on puisse garantir l'ouverture des
écoles des collèges et des lycées du
département
pour ce qui concerne la semaine dernière
sauf deux écoles avaient fermé il n'y a
pas eu d'accélération pendant ce
week-end c'est à dire en termes
d'ouverture de fermeture possible ni
d'école ni de classe
donc la situation aujourd'hui est une
situation où effectivement sous contrôle
la préfète
voilà donc ça ce sont toutes les mesures
qui sont mises en oeuvre au titre du
premier pilier de la d'extraits de la
doctrine tester alerté protéger c'est à
dire les le volet tester au titre du
volet alerté ce que nous mettons en
oeuvre
déjà depuis le week-end dernier c'est le
renforcement des demandes de respect des
gestes barrières et des protocoles
sanitaires
le week end dernier déjà tout le
week-end des forces de sécurité police
et gendarmerie ont effectué un certain
nombre d'opérations de contrôles auprès
des établissements qui reçoivent du
public de façon à s'assurer que les
protocoles sanitaires sont bien
respectés et aussi des opérations auprès
de nos concitoyens pour leur rappeler la
nécessité de respecter les gestes
barrière de respecter la distanciation
de porter le masque est vraiment je je
je le demande à tous à toutes et à
toutes et à tous d'être très respectueux
des gestes-barrières et à tous les
établissements qui reçoivent du public
au cinéma au théâtre restaurateur au
commerce et c'est d'être
particulièrement vigilant dans le
respect des protocoles sanitaires et on
rappe en demandant au public d'être très
attentif à se laver
avec du gel hydroalcoolique en entre à
respecter les distances
ça fait partie des éléments qui
permettront que la situation si yannick
à ce pouvoir bien maîtrisé et puis pour
se protéger il ya également le
dispositif de rétro trasim ça la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie et la grèce
continue à poursuivre toutes les mesures
de croisement des données pour remonter
les chaînes de contamination et puis il
ya bien sûr également le dispositif
d'isolement toujours avoir en tête
lorsque quelqu'un est contaminée ou
lorsqu'on est qu'à contacter qu'il faut
savoir s'isoler être très respectueux
des mesures d'isolement et surtout ne
pas hésiter si certaines personnes ont
besoin d'un hébergement spécifique parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas s'isoler chez
elle à faire appel à la préfecture et à
la celle historia territoriale d'appui à
l'isolément parce que nous pouvons
mettre à disposition des logements nous
pouvons mettre à disposition des
services de fourniture des repas le plat
la nécessité de faim les opérations
d'isolement sont vraiment importantes
pour éviter
vous le savez tous la circulation du
virus est là et pour briser les chaînes
de contamination et puis bien sûr et
puis bien sûr la vaccination elle est
déjà bien avancé dans ce département 46%
de la population landaise
déjà reçu au moins une injection 24 24%
a reçu les deux injections et nous
allons déployer des dispositifs de
vaccination renforcée pour maîtriser la
situation pour comment dire ramener la
situation sanitaire à une situation
encore meilleur d'une part toutes les
personnes doivent aller se faire
vacciner dans les centres de vaccination
le plus proche de chez eux ou médecine
de ville
pharmacien et puis nous allons mettre en
place des dispositifs spécifiques de
1500 doses de vaccins vont être
mobilisés dans un certain nombre de deux
centres de vaccination et de maisons de
santé pluriprofessionnelle et nous
allons également organiser des
opérations de vaccination dans les
entreprises ou les hébergements
spécialisés qui sont plus
particulièrement confrontés à la
présence de ce variant dit variant
indien voilà sur les sur les trois
volets ce que l'on pouvait ce que l'on
vous pouvez vous dire maintenant si vous
avez des questions bien sûr elles sont
les bienvenus
oh pardon excusez moi j'en ai oublié un
élément très important j'ai oublié un
élément important dans la partie pour
rappeler les gestes barrière il ya bien
sûr les forces de sécurité police et
gendarmerie qui ont comme ans qui
effectue des opérations de contrôle
régulièrement qui ont effectué tout le
week end et qui continueront à le faire
il y a aussi ce qu'on appelle les
médiateurs lutte anti qu'ovide nous
avons plus de deux équipes de médiateurs
qui sont mises en oeuvre d'une part pas
la croix rouge d'autre part par
l'association départementale de
protection civile qui effectuent des
opérations très régulièrement depuis
plusieurs semaines dans tout le
département et qui vont dès demain
refaire des opérations très spécifique
sur les zones où on a pu observer une
présence plus marquée du variant indien
pour là aussi rappeler les gestes
barrière proposer du dépistage si
nécessaire ça fait partie du de
l'ensemble notre plan d'action
oh
oui ce sera possible également sur le
département des landes
comme je voulais dit en introduction
nous avons un taux d'incidence qui a
augmenté dans le département alors que
la tendance nationale est plutôt à la à
la diminution
le taux d'incidence est supérieure à la
moyenne régionale supérieure à la
moyenne nationale donc des indicateurs
qui nous amène à beaucoup de vigilance
mais qui ne sont pas de nature à
remettre en question la deuxième phase
de déconfinement d'autant que nous avons
tous ce plan d'action qui est mis en
place pour maîtriser la situation qui
est sous contrôle
ça fait
si si
vos estimations l'est
on n'a pas de certitudes
faut se bouger j'ai presque alors
simplement on va reprendre l'ensemble de
dépistage c'est à dire sur des sur des
patients positifs donc ceux de ces
derniers jours et puis ce également sur
la semaine de façon à conforter les
analyses aujourd'hui quand on fait les
analyses on a
connaissance des variants qui existent
pour autant un certain nombre de
résultats sortent en indéterminée donc
c'est pour ça qu'ont donc on va cibler
sur un volume de 100 à 200 tests pour
lesquels on va demander un séquençage
donc notamment pour confirmer des
diagnostics qui sortirait dans la
première approche de criblage en
indéterminée voilà et après il ya eu les
dix il ya une autre mesure puisque on
fait une opération flash demain surtout
les résultats positifs ou là on va
envoyer d'emblée et 70 résultats donc
c'est pas au fil de l'eau c'est pas au
fur et à mesure d'une semaine là c'est
vraiment prendre les 70 à 80 positive
qu'on a habituellement sur une journée
dans le département
donc les prendre et donc les faire
analyser d'emblée sur la méthode ces
séquençages
à l'origine
alors effectivement on n'est pas au bout
du rétro de racing c'est un travail qui
est mené bon partenariat avec bien
évidemment santé publique france 2 puis
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
ce qu'on peut vous dire simplement c'est
que vendredi et pour illustrer un peu ce
que c'est que le rétro racing vendredi
on était à peu près à 15 patients dit
zéro c'est à dire on n'avait pas fait
les correspondances étaient simplement
des foyers aujourd'hui on n'est plus
qu'à neuf donc ça veut dire qu'on est en
train effectivement de tisser les liens
de deux tracés d'essayer de reconstituer
chacune des situations et pour
aujourd'hui pour répondre très
clairement votre site à votre question
non on n'a pas encore terminé ce travail
pour identifier la source
on va dire initial d'origine delà de la
diffusion de ce virus ou de variole
on est on est effectivement à 29,4
crible et donc vous souvenez il y avait
eu deux cas c'est quand c'est la semaine
d'avant
la semaine de la semaine d'avant donc le
29 mai donkey kong qui étaient sur une
autre partie du territoire
là on vous parle bien des 29 cas qui ont
été criblés positif aux variants donc
c'est bien voilà c'est bien les liens
qu'on essaye de tracer entre ses 29 k et
puis on en a parlé d'une cinquantaine
également parce qu'il ya parfois des
proches qui sont eux-mêmes dans le même
foyer et qui eux n'ont pas été criblée
on demande donc ça d'épargné notre plan
d'action qu'on arrive à un criblage
proche de 100% désormais sur l'ensemble
de nos cas positifs quand ça pas été
fait si vous voulez on les a pas
répercutée sur les sur la trentaine et
c'est pour ça qu'on a dit on soupçonnait
qu'il n'est pas 30 milliards et 50 parce
qu'on a des membres de familles qui sont
parfois positif donc s'ils sont dans le
même foyer en général ça va être le même
dario
alors si on demande globalement si vous
voulez on reprend va reprendre les 29
situation c'est à dire l'ensemble des
foyers pour les retravailler est ce que
c'est bien du variant indien bon
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a défini
demain l'objectif c'est bien de savoir
si ces de l'indien muté parce que bon
vous le savez il ya eu ni varia indien
il ya plusieurs ya plusieurs cas de
figure donc c'est bien ce qu'on va
rechercher la et puis globalement après
l'idée c'est bien de travailler sur les
futurs résultats qu'on va avoir sur
l'ensemble du département
pour aller plus loin également et pour
donc c'est quand c'est une partie alors
la lumière pourquoi 100 150 ou 200 vont
simplement parce qu'on travaille sur des
méthodes analyses qui sont réservées
dans certains laboratoires qui peuvent
pas être fait dans tous leurs jeux par
les d 13 laboratoires qu'on avait cité
donc forcément c'est un choix qui est
fait d'une priorisation sur un certain
nombre de cas dans les prochains qui
arrive dans la semaine
je parlais je parlais tout à l'heure
effectivement d'un centre d'hébergement
personnes fragiles donc oui il ya
effectivement il ya un centre d'accueil
de demandeurs d'asile qui est ciblé dont
j'ai parlé de centres d'hébergement tout
à l'heure
la question la question c'est est-ce
qu'un cada centre d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile étaient concernés
donc la réponse est oui
dans nos situations on avait parlé tout
à l'heure d'entreprises et de centres
d'hébergement
donc j'avais intitulé personnes fragiles
donc il s'agit bien d'un centre
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile
oui qui est concerné on a parlé j'ai
bien indiqué que sur alors je répète la
question
est ce que demain est ce qu'on est bien
sûr cinq clusters donc il faut qu'il
faut bien se dire que ces 29 cas
positifs ils sont il va il représente 15
familles
sur ses quinze familles en effet des
lierres aujourd'hui dans le rétro tra
singh en se disant bon il n'ya plus que
neuf branches sur 15
voilà donc on voit là on pousse toujours
les investigations plus loin pour
essayer de faire les recoupements
parmi ces recoupements il ya bien sûr
les situations professionnelles pas
simplement les familles simplement les
adresses des situations professionnelles
les lieux d'hébergement c'est pour ça
qu'on est sur un centre d'accueil de
demandeurs d'asile
et puis après il ya effectivement des
entreprises qui sont concernés donc on a
ciblé cinq entreprises parce qu'on a au
moins un cas voire plusieurs cas
concernés donc ça veut dire que ça peut
être effectivement des personnes qui
soient travailler ensemble soit le virus
est passé d'une personne à une autre au
sein d'une entreprise donc cinq
entreprises
absolument on fait à la fois du
dépistage j'ai parlé de dépistage tout à
l'heure donc on veut aller vers ces
entreprises faire du dépistage pcr et
puis également travaillé sur la
vaccination proposer la vaccination
bien bien avoir en tête que sur ces 29
situation je le redis on n'était pas sûr
des personnes vaccinées
donc même sur une première injection
simplement trois personnes avec une
première injection
donc l'objectif bien évidemment c'est
aussi de limiter la diffusion en a l'air
au plus près en proposant la vaccination
est donc au plus près des habitats ou au
plus près dans des situations
professionnelles
[Musique]
porter
alors je répète la question on a parlé
du leclerc de tyrosse si vous venez de
nous rejoindre en direct sur figaro life
lefigaro.fr et sur youtube nous venons
d'assister un point presse depuis
mont-de-marsan dans les landes en
nouvelles aquitaine au sujet du variant
indien variant du kobe de 19 variant à
dire qu'il y a inquiète les autorités
sanitaires
puisqu'il ya un certain nombre de
kloster et de personnes détectées
positive à ce variant indien je suis
accompagné en plateau et en direct de
marque chère qui est journaliste au
service science du figaro et qui répond
à toutes vos questions et vos
commentaires diffusés sur les tchats et
youtube et figaro live en ce moment et
en direct marques chères qui vous l'avez
écouté comme moi il ya d'abord eu une
intervention de la préfète des landes
cécile vigo de keyser suivie de
l'intervention du directeur de la rs des
landes didier couteaud qui est
d'ailleurs encore en train de parler et
bruno brevet est intervenu également au
sujet des collèges et lycées il est
directeur académique des services de
l'éducation nationale des langues et
qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir de ces
arbres de ces interventions qui avait
pour but de donner un peu un plan
d'action en fait des mesures qui étaient
qui vise à à freiner cette épidémie ce
qu'on peut retenir c'est qu'on n'en sait
pas beaucoup plus
à part la répartition par tranche d'âge
des 20 de notre cas qui ont été annoncés
vendredi
on sait que sur ces 29 ko quand présente
un caractère de gravité
y'a pas de capitalisation en 400 ans
réanime peut-être une personne il ya
peut-être des personnes hospitalisées
mais parce qu'ils ont ils n'ont pas
précisé
il nous dit qu'il ya aucun aucune
personne en réanimer louis donc il ya
peut-être des gens qui ont été
hospitalisés mais il ya personnes en
réanimation et parmi elles on peut
définir un peu le profil des personnes
concernées il ya cinq personnes qui ont
plus de 50 ans et une qui a plus de 75
ans et la personne de plus de 75 ans a
été vaccinée mais la deuxième
j'ai mission la deuxième descente en
rappel d'injection a été fait
deux jours auparavant oui donc on va
dire que c'est l'ensemble des ces
personnes citées de ces profils étaient
hors schéma vaccinal
voilà comme ça avec te mange donc ils
n'étaient pas vaccinés donc ça c'est
assez important et un peu rassurant ce
qui l'est moins c'est que si on les 15
patients 0 donc ce qu'il fallait
remonter à savoir s'il avait été
contaminée par qui il avait été
contaminée et on a neuf qui reste dans
le flou on ne sait pas si ce sont des
cas autochtones ou si c'est des gens qui
ont été contaminés alors il ya
apparemment il ya des des clusters il ya
cinq entreprises qui ont été avancées
dont on ne connaît pas les noms et un
centre d'hébergement
quand vous dites cinq entreprises c'est
à dire cinq sociétés entreprise basée
dans les landes dans les langues dans
lesquelles on a détecté un certain
nombre d'individus voilà autant
ciellement sont positifs aux copies 19
et aux variants diaw noah exactement et
est donc un centre d'hébergement
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile
ça c'est une personne qui était
demandeur d'asile qui serait
porteuse alors ensuite il ya eu quand
même des précisions c'est pour ça je
disais où on n'en sait pas beaucoup plus
c'est à dire que il a parlé de 29 k
séquences et vendredi mais ils veulent
refaire des tests de séquençage
oui c'est en fait on va presser reculait
alors les scans ce qu'a dit la préfète
effectivement elle a juste pour faire un
petit point et un résumé de ce qu'a dit
la préfète dans ce sur ce point presse
donc et sur la situation
elle a rappelé que la situation n'était
pas particulièrement inquiétante mais
qu'elle méritait vigilance le taux
d'incidence augmentent mais restent
modérées pour reprendre ses propos il
est situé entre 80 et 100 et que la
présence de personnes affectées par
variant indien et bien et bien réel et 7
préfète a mis en avant donc un plan
d'action basé sur les trois piliers de
tester alerté protéger en rappelant qu'
il y allait avoir un renfort des
dispositifs et des opérations de test et
l'identification du virus qu'il allait
qu'ils allait alerter plus massivement
avec un renforcement des actions et des
gestes barrières et enfin protégés par
l'isolément et la vaccination est le
directeur de la rs marcheurs qui est
intervenue après a effectivement parlé
de on va leur revenir dessus mais vous
parlez de séquençage il a parlé
également de criblage pour remonter un
peu le la source de la de l'épidémie est
voir d'où viennent les premières
personnes infectées alors quand ce
directeur de la rs didier couteaud parle
d'abord de conforter les diagnostics sur
l'existence du variant indien et il part
de criblage qu'est ce que c'est que le
criblage déterminer des mutations
caractéristiques de certains des
variants donc on va rechercher leurs en
l'occurrence pour le variant indien
deux mutations principal la mutation eu
4 184 cas là le qui a 100 84 q et puis
là l 452 air donc ce sont des mutations
qui sont portés par une partie du virus
de la protéine du virus sur ce qu'on
appelle le spicules ce sont les petites
pointes qui les fameuses petites one
voilà qui est qui couvre la surface du
virus et qui viennent s'accrocher et qui
permettent de déterminer s'il s'agit
plutôt du variant indien le ou d'un
autre type de variants et là il ya des
mutations qui sont caractéristiques là l
452 m
hélas
eux 480 4 mai
on ne nous a pas donné les résultats on
nous a parlé de variants indiens sans
nous dire s'il s'agissait du haillan
indien le plus préoccupant le variant
delta ou d'invariants indien un peu
moins préoccupante
le capa ou encore dans notre île c'est
le séquençage qui permettra c'est une
étape après criblage il ya le séquençage
il en a également parlé en découle un
résident la rse des landes
c'est un complément d'analysé qu'ils
vont effectuer un pour confirmer les
résultats sur environ 100 tests c'est à
dire que déjà d'ores et déjà des tests
positifs mais vont aller creuser encore
alors ils vont revoir sur les thèses qui
ont été positifs et qui était
indéterminée et puis ils ont l'intention
de faire une enquête flash
il l'a pas dit manière explicite mais
c'est ce que j'ai compris dans son
propos c'est à dire qu'ils vont prendre
le nombre de cas positifs dans une
journée celle d'aujourd'hui qui sont
généralement entre 70 à 84 et 80 cas par
jour et ils vont les envoyer au centre
national d infection respiratoire à lyon
pour séquençage et pour déterminer quel
est le pourcentage d
des questions dépend des patients et des
baryons qui sont concernés voilà donc
c'est ce que ça va nous apprendre alors
dans quelques jours on n'aura pas le
résultat c'est sa morale résultant d'une
semaine dans une semaine ce qui est
assez long d'ailleurs ils ont rappelé
par ailleurs directeur de la rs des
langues chacun aille et le plus possible
vers les lieux de dépistage et fasse
faire des tests pcr dès que des soupçons
se portent sur son état de santé ou dès
qu'on se demande pour quelle raison on a
quelques symptômes
il ya aussi l'inspecteur d'académie
local on va dire des landes qui est
intervenu dans ce point presse en disant
que tous les établissements restent
ouverts il n'y a pas d'augmentation de
classes ou d'écoles qui ont fermé que le
protocole sanitaire et de fait respecter
bien respecté il a parlé cependant de
tests salivaires et puis d'autotest
distribué depuis trois semaines pour
justifier que la situation est sous
contrôle
oui mais ça il faut regarder ça avec la
plus grande circonspection enfin la plus
grande prudence parce que
il ya très peu de tests salivaires qui
sont effectivement réalisé je n'aime pas
l'idée du nombre de classes qui lie à et
du nombre d'élèves
mais ils ont parlé d'une augmentation de
3 à 6 milles du nombre de tests
salivaires et de la mise à disposition
d'un millier d'autres tests pour
l'ensemble des lycées du département de
des landes que je pense qu'il ya quand
même un peu plus qu'un millier de
lycéens dans l'ensemble du département
si vous vous rejoignez en ce moment
direct nous venons d'assister au point
presse de la préfète des landes au sujet
du variant indien variante delta qui
suscite l'inquiétude des autorités
sanitaires sur place un nouvel aquitaine
je suis avec marchèrent qui journaliste
au service science du figaro pour
répondre à vos questions et vos
commentaires sur ce variant indien qui
est comme l'avait dit marc cherkli au
début de cet entretien présent également
sur d'autres territoires en france et en
occurrence l'île de france
ce variant indien dont on entend parler
depuis plusieurs semaines fait peur mais
du coup on nous demande de ne pas nous
inquiéter que la situation est sous
contrôle que les personnes vaccinées a
priori ne risque entre guillemets rien
que l'éclat positif aux variants indiens
sont des personnes qui étaient hors
schéma vaccinal
pourquoi en fait il faudrait avoir peur
de caisse qui inquiète qu'est ce qui
fait peur les autorités sanitaires par
rapport à cette situation
si on la campagne vaccinale est menée
jusqu'à terme et que on est a priori
protéger parce qu'il ya 75 % de la
population française qui n'est pas
vacciné donc qui est qui peut être
contaminé par ce ces variants donc
c'est une large proportion de la
population
donc il faut s'en prémunir et surtout ce
qui est inquiétant enfin ce qu'il faut
regarder en fait la raison de la
vigilance c'est que ce variant indien ne
devienne pas n'échappe pas complètement
au comptoir le contrôle par rappeler qu
en bretagne au royaume uni
varian indien et maintenant désormais 76
% des nouveaux quarts 76% que 6000 car
je crois à la semaine dernière pourrait
arriver à cette situation en france donc
on pourrait perdre le contrôle c'est
probable c'est probable selon vous ben
j'ai bien eux-mêmes avec le respect des
gestes barrière elle est la mise en
place de dispositifs dédiés
il n'y a pas de raison que ce qui s'est
passé avec le premier variant le variant
anglais ne se produise pas aujourd'hui
avec le vario maintien voilà il faut
qu'on m'apporte des éléments pour
comprendre pourquoi est-ce que ce coup
là ce serait différent de ce qui s'est
passé auparavant
en début d'année on nous a expliqué que
le variant angles est le
varian alpha était sous contrôle on nous
a annoncé que le
le taux de prévalence de ce variant
lundi anglais alpha maintenant dans la
population était de moins d'un pour cent
ou autour d'un pour cent
finalement quand on a eu le résultat un
mois plus tard on a appris que c'est les
troisièmes 3% dont plus de deux fois
plus que ce qu'on nous avait annoncé
initialement
et après on nous a dit ne vous inquiétez
pas ce sera dans deux à trois mois que
il deviendra majoritaire dès fin mars il
était de l'imagerie donc pourquoi est-ce
que ce qui s'est produit avec le vario
historique le varia anglais ne se
produirait pas à nouveau avec le variant
indien est-ce qu'on peut pas considérer
que notre stratégie vaccinale qui était
basée sur la vaccination des personnes
les plus fragiles et les plus âgés est
un parti pris ou une stratégie qui
empêche justement une propagation
massive du variant à dire parce que au
royaume uni ils n'ont vacciné que enfin
la masse de la population sans
considérer qu'il y avait que telle ou
telle catégorie à vacciner en priorité
c'est tout à fait exact ça protège ce
après midi les personnes les plus
fragiles et ça évite qu'ils aient une
explosion du nombre demain il n'empêche
pas
nombre un nombre accru de contamination
ça marcherait si on avait 60 70 80
pourtant ça dépend ce qu'on appelle le
nid des troupeaux les deux groupes
ça dépendra de cela de savoir quel
pourcentage de la population française
qui est nécessaire d'avoir lac signer
pour que l'épidémie arrête de trois
pages et on l'a ce chiffre ben justement
on l'a pas ça dépend des études ça
dépend des des valides estime que c'est
entre 60 et 80% et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui explique sa nouvelle stratégie en
france sur la vaccination des
adolescents parce que entre 12 et 18 ans
et ça à partir de 12 ans selon certains
vaccins qui auront qu'ils ont fait a
priori leurs preuves
du coup une autre émission notre direct
touch touche bientôt à sa fin
peut-être marche est requis journaliste
au service science du figaro vous
pourriez nous dire comment à ceux qui
nous regardent en ce moment comme et qui
ne sont pas vaccinés ou dont la la la
vaccination n'est pas achevé et comment
on peut empêcher ce variant de circuler
mais il faut respecter les gestes
barrière c'est la principale
mesures de prévention et en cas de doute
aller se faire tester simplement donc
pour aller faire pour aller se faire
tester on se connecte sur internet les
informations souiba soit sa pharmacie
soit son labo soit enfin la pharmacie on
peut acheter un autotest à le faire chez
soi si on préfère qui a un acte que
l'acte soit réalisé par quelqu'un on
peut demander un test antigénique
à son pharmacien et sinon on peut aller
dans un laboratoire
alors pour l'avoir fait récemment
plusieurs fois un test pcr vous les avez
la possibilité de vous faire tester très
rapidement via des créneaux précis en
allant sur d'octo ligue site un site qui
est quand même de renommée maintenant
assez importante dans ta plante spcr et
en mettant le lieu dans lequel vous
souhaiteriez le faire le département où
la ville vous avez des droits certain
nombre de lieux que ce soit des
formations ou des centres dédiés avec
des bénévoles et c'est très facile
d'aller se faire tester vous avez en
général une réponse par sms dans les 24
heures donc on va dire mais c'est exact
sauf pour la pharmacie la pharmacie ne
vous fera pas de la pharmacie ne fait
pas dans l'officine spcr par exemple
voici que vous envoie dans des petites
tentes qui sont à l'extérieur de la
pharmacie j'ai pu le tester
effectivement pas très loin d'ici
et c'est une infirmière ou 1h médecin
qui vous fait le prélèvement nasal
voilà je crois qu'on dit ça comme ça
prenait enfin jaloux non non non mais
l'idée c'est que la pharmacie elle même
ne réalise pas le test pcr parce qu'il
faut des grosses machines béria vous
voulez dire sur l'analyse qu'on analyse
prélèvement dit elle est faite
les laboratoires de laboratoire c'est
plutôt bien organisé
voilà notre intervention en direct avec
l' expertise de marche est requis
journaliste au service science du figaro
concernant ce point presse qui a été
donnée par la préfète des landes
on va là nommé cécile bigot de keyser
ainsi que didier couteaud directeur de
l'agencé régionale de santé des landes
et en présence également du directeur
académique de cervidés services de
l'éducation nationale
bruno brevets depuis mon marsan dans les
landes et bien nous avons pu vous donner
un point assez précis de ce qu'il s'est
dit et des mesures mises en place par la
région nouvelle aquitaine et le
département des landes pour maintenir
cette épidémie circonscrire cette
épidémie éviter que le variant indien
dont il était question aujourd'hui se
propage sur le reste du territoire en
tout cas voilà nous arrivons au terme de
ce direct merci encore de nous avoir
suivis en direct d'avoir fait part de
vos questions et vos commentaires merci
marché requis pour vos éclairages et les
réponses que vous avez apporté à nos
internautes fidèles en titre actrice
cross l'un des plus fidèles et qui a
posé un certain nombre de questions
aujourd'hui je salue également le roots
et ouzou qui a est intervenue et zorro
bothorel pour ses commentaires et ses
éloges merci beaucoup à bientôt